m
qu'ils s'appellent dynamique voilà
jamiroquai mieux nous jean michel jarre
news jean michel jarre évidemment je le
connais et oui je suis un grand fan de
jean michel jarre est ce que jean-michel
peut revenir pour serrer la main de
jamiroquai
alors jean michel jamiroquai vient de
dire qu'il était un grand fan de un
grand fan de vous est ce que vous êtes
un grand fan de lui oui absolument
passer c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui a un
style totalement particulier qui use je
pense qu'on se retrouve c'est qu'il a
une manière de traiter le son qui est
totalement unique dans dans un 2e
catégorie de musique totalement
différente mais mais c'est avant tout du
son du maroc c'est pour ça que depuis le
départ moi c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
branché mais immédiatement
indépendamment de son talent de
performeurs et de haut niveau du son
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
immédiatement ses s'est décalé par
rapport à tout un genre de musique qui
existaient et qui en a fait une pâte qui
viennent une patte unique et particulier
il te connais d'accord mais de you know
jean pierre raffarin
merci jean michel merci d'être venu
saluer johnny
salut sur lui